[Musique]
bonsoir à tous pardon du retard
bienvenue dans le gros figure du figaro
on est à direct on est avec vous et
c'est figaro life faut-il un front
républicain contre mélenchon et la
france insoumise ça c'est la question
qu'on pose sur le site du figaro depuis
le milieu de la journée je vous propose
d'en débattre ce soir avec vincent
trémolet de villers bonsoir d'un fort
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
figaro et coordinateur entre autres des
loges de la politique un ouvrage
collectif sur les grands textes et les
grands grands auteurs et c'est aux
éditions tallandier est avec nous avec
vous ce soir une autre éditrice valérie
sa portable mais valérie non mais j'aime
bien le 10 mais bien deux c'est isabelle
saporta bien entendu honte à moi comme
un ancien journaliste est alors à tout
contrôle et on s'en fout et du tri
serait faudrait écologiste dans l'âme on
va vous voyez vous aviez quasiment tous
oui excusez moi mais c'est parce que
vous savez pourquoi parce que eric
besson mais c'est d'abord parce que ça
fait quand même longtemps vous n'êtes
pas venus nous voir c'est pas loin du
coeur même si on en a je sais pas si on
en a mais c'est parce qu'ils occupent
aussi une valérie saporta au figaro et
donc voilà et c'est comme ça que en
écrivant trop vite la prochaine fois je
vérifierai merci d'être de faire le folk
le fact checking avec nous ce soir
vous êtes l'auteur de l'indispensable
entre autres rendez nous la france en
finir avec la caste qui paralyse notre
pays et là encore c'est aux éditions
fayard
l'autre question qu'on vous pose on va y
revenir l'autre question qu'on vous pose
ce soir c'est quelle sera selon vous
l'impact des élections régionales sur
2022 et bien on attend charles haas
hanche et isabelle vos points de vue et
bien sûr les vôtres chers internautes
mais d'abord si vous aimez l'histoire de
la quatrième république son front du
refus pour barrer à l'époque la route au
parti communiste vous allez adorer la
séquence du jour elles se résument dans
la question posée donc sur le site du
figaro faut-il un front républicain
contre mélenchon et la france insoumise
alors pour manuel valls qui appellent à
voter
justement contre l'union de la gauche en
ile de france
et bien la réponse ne fait aucun doute
en écoute
aussi dire qu'il ya en effet un danger à
partir de l'addition des trois listes de
gauche fassent en plus à l'abstention
massive
alors il faut voter pour valérie
pécresse il ne faut pas hésiter et et
comme je suis franc direct
je voterai valérie pécresse parce que je
considère qu'il y a ce danger est alors
vous avez maintenant d'autres nuances
d'autres points de vue celui du
conseiller régional ps sortant françois
kalfon invité ici même sur le plateau du
talk hamidi qui fait cette différence au
jour d'aujourd'hui
monsieur mélenchon est devenu un
problème pour la gauche il faut le dire
clairement
et quand j'entends ses lieutenants le
défendre je n'entends pas le même
discours
jean luc mélenchon a versé dans le
complotisme 1 2 t de façon tout à fait
évidente et de manière assez abjecte
alors ses lieutenants monsieur 4-1 ce
monsieur corbières l'ont défendu autant
qu'il le pouvait le coq rake monsieur
coquerel mais que je quand je les
entends s'exprimer je n'entends pas ce
complotisme alors parmi la lieutenant de
jean luc mélenchon il y en a une que n'a
pas cité françois kalfon c'est
clémentine autain mais anne hidalgo a
abordé son kite
paysans du nord tient au teint est gelée
mélenchon c'est pas la même chose je
pense que ça n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose et il faut se donner des
chances de dépasser des choses qui sont
choquants du
or donc on peut déplacer des choses qui
sont choquants donc avec eric coquerel
adrien catnat alexis corbière et
clémentine autain l'instant c'est
mélenchon l'ennemi le seul ennemi mais
c'est pas mélenchon l'ennemi mélenchon
peut s'exprimer tant qu'ils restent dans
un cadre que la loi autorise il dit ce
qu'il veut apprécié dit des bêtises ils
ont dit beaucoup bas il fait très peu de
voix et voilà parce que l'ailier il
était quand même 1 19% et je pense que
s'il continue sur le chemin sur lequel
il finira à sept ou huit mois je pense
que la question est les plus profondes
elle est quand même dans un
bouleversement idéologique dont la
gauche est victime et dont les effets
vont jusqu'à jean luc mélenchon il ya
toute une partie de la gauche qui
aujourd'hui croit à un certain nombre de
notions que l'on qualifie d'
intersectionnelle un certain nombre de
luttes qui se dégage du principe même de
l'universalisme républicain donc quand
on dit qu'il ya un problème à éclairer
le public c'est pas un jugement moral
que l'on porterait nous en étant les
dépositaires de la république en disant
que n'ont pas le droit d'y avoir accès
mais c'est eux qui la disqualifie en
disant que son principe même est un
principe de domination donc à partir de
là ça c'est la doctrine en profondeur
elle remonte et elle arrive dans les
propos de certains élus qui veulent
correspondre à la fois à l'atmosphère
dans laquelle il évolue à une partie de
leur électorat
je crois que c'est vraiment ça la très
grande difficulté devant laquelle on est
hélas le la question que l'on voit
apparaître avec 7,7 l'histone en
ile-de-france et comment dire le jeu
lyon voilà socialiste soit comment on
pourrait dire ça mais c'est celle écume
des choses il ya des courants beaucoup
plus profond qu'il a sont très
superficielles ou en compte ce qui sont
là sont très sérieux c'est à dire que je
ne crois pas que audrey pulvar soit où
que je ne crois pas je pense qu audrey
pulvar est obligé de céder un certain
nombre de choses à une certain nouvelles
formes de pensée parce que on
l'atmosphère politique dans laquelle
elle vit le lui impose
et c'est ça et c'est un ennui c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut réfléchir je vois
simplement dire que ce sont des choses
il avait saporta les a vus aussi assez
tôt mais que nous on a vu émerger aller
il ya quatre cinq six ans je me souviens
notamment de papier que nous et laurent
bouvet nous disant qu aux etats unis ces
phénomènes allait arriver chez nous et
je me souviens d'amis très proches et
très intelligent et très articulé qui me
disent être complètement panneaux figaro
vous intéresser à des trucs dont
personne ne parle
qui concerne des minorités extrêmement
étroites et qui est qu'ils n'arriveront
jamais dans le champ public fait
aujourd'hui ça arrive dans le débat
public
à tel point que ça arrive dans des
élections locales un certain nombre de
ces notions sont invoquées par valérie
pécresse contre ces gens qui veule et
défend isabelle vous avez consacré votre
premier livre à 7,7 gauche qui à gauche
de la gauche est également alternet
altermondialiste est ce que vous pensez
comme jean paul huchon que mélenchon est
sorti du rivage républicain quel est
votre justement ce point de vue et est
ce que ça vous paraît absurde de se
poser la question ce sont du front
républicain par rapport à mélenchon
alors je veux dire je vais revenir moi
par contre pardonnez moi à l écume des
choses parce que cette histoire de
rendre moins que c'est un peu d'ambiance
et un peu les qu'une des choses c'est à
dire que moi je voudrais bien pensé que
sa part livré forte s'il n'avait pas
lui-même fait alliance avec le parti
communiste avec les verts quand il était
président de région il l'a fait à deux
reprises il est vrai que jean paul
huchon de jean paul huchon il a fait à
la veille du second tour en 2010 il a
lui même participé à l'élection de
julien bayou qu'aujourd'hui voue aux
gémonies donc le patron des verts ou xul
est ce que je trouve un petit peu
absurde là dedans c'est que ça vient au
fond du même ben 1 ces gens viennent
tous du même pas quand j'entends
notre ancien premier ministre manuel
valls dire que c'est terrible cette
gauche et dans cette liste celle de
pulvar dont vous parlais tout à l'heure
il y avait mac os et mac os c'était sa
propre ministre et mac os était aussi
c'était emmanuelle cosse c'était aussi
la vice président de région de monsieur
huchon ont ciblé moi c'est ça qui me
gêne c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'on
est plutôt et ça c'est quand même un
vrai travers de la gauche ça peut l'être
de la droite aussi enfin lancer la
gauche ces règlements de comptes à ok
corral et ça je trouve que c'est assez
médiocre maintenant si on doit revenir
sur la profondeur dont je vous
interromps est ce que il faut pas voir
dans dans l'attitude et le refus de jean
paul huchon et de soutenir cette cette
liste justement cette évolution
idéologique à gauche dont il me parlait
vincent écouter est ce qu'il ya une
vraie différence entre le bayou
d'aujourd'hui et le bayoud il ya 11 ans
j'en suis pas tout à fait certaine je
pense qu'il s'est plutôt snj qu'autre
chose
je pense juste quand j'entends madame
hidalgo dire qu'elle découvre les verts
avec lac avec lesquels elle gouverne
depuis bientôt vingt ans malgré tout
parce qu'entre delanoë et ses propres
mandats successifs et qu elle les trouve
non républicain alors que c'est quand
même grâce à leur voix qu'elle a été
élue je trouve qu'on est un peu dans la
tartufferie maintenant si vous voulez me
demander à titre personnel ce que je
pense du fait qu'une partie de la gauche
a abandonné au fond la lutte des classes
pour partir vers des luttes
communautaire je suis en parfait accord
avec vous moi je pense que d'ailleurs ça
remonte à bien je pense que c'est la
marche des beurs c'est au fond on avait
une marche qui disait reconnaissez nous
est fait en sorte que nous soyons un clé
dans cette société en a qui on a dit on
reconnaît votre différence ça n'était
pas la différence qui le demandaient
mais l'inclusion donc ça je suis
parfaitement d'accord avec vous je pense
qu'on s'est perdu d'ailleurs une suite
pardonnez moi mais il suffit de voir les
candidats que propose par cas par
exemple parti socialiste je n'ai rien
contre raphaël glucksmann que je trouve
très brillant enfin malgré tout c'est un
héritier je n'ai rien contre audrey
pulvar qui est sans doute très brillante
aussi c'est une ancienne vedette de la
télévision
enfin si le parti de jean jaurès n'a
finalement que des csp + plus plus plus
à proposer on est quand même loin des
rives des classes populaires et qu'ils
ne s'étonnent pas dès lors que ces
classes populaires
votre massivement ou s'abstiennent
massivement ont d'ailleurs pour le
rassemblement national
donc si voulez moi c'est ça qui
m'inquiète le plus c'est au fond on est
dans un entre soi le plus total et à
l'intérieur de cet entre soi le plus
total en plus on se castagnent 1 parce
que monsieur huchon me témine de
découvrir en fait avec qui il a déjà
gouverné c'est ça que je trouve tout à
l'est rien vous avez absolument raison
mais je pense qu'il ya une nouveauté
c'est dans le rapport de forces c'est à
dire que dans le cynisme qui a été celui
d'un certain nombre de sociaux
démocrates qui étaient
sociaux-démocrates une fois que les
portes étaient fermées qui était en
privé mais qui tenait des discours plus
à gauche et le son mais c'est françois
hollande
il y avait l'idée que la stratégie terra
nova donc défini en 2011 qui tente qui
tendait à sacrifier les catégories
populaires pour aller vers les minorités
cette stratégie sera utile pour être élu
et qu'ensuite on ferait un peu près ce
qu'on veut et ce qu'on voit maintenant à
gauche c'est que ces forces minoritaires
sont en train par leur hégémonie de
devenir des forces centrales c'est ça
qui est à mon avis c'est ça qui est
nouveau et alors nous la sincérité des
uns et des autres en sais rien mais on
voit très bien et vous parliez d'hidalgo
je pense qu'ils d'algos au fond c'est un
socialisme poste chute du mur très
social démocratisant avec une forme de
libertarisme sur les questions de
société et un peu d'écologie mais au
fond elle est obligée de composer des
gens beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
radicaux qu'elle parce que ça c'est vrai
ils ont joué avec mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qui jusqu'ici ils pensaient
un peu comme les gens vont se parler on
entend parler c'est que c'était marginal
que c'était des phénomène marginal qui
avait une possibilité électorale mais
qu'à la fin on ne rentrerai pas dans ces
luttes
je suis pas quand il faisait du
féminisme et on serait pas qu'on
aboutira alice coffin
il pensait pas que ce serait possible
dabo terrassa et là il se retrouve dans
cette situation ça moi ça me paraît pour
eux
ingérable c'est à dire que maintenant
ils sont dépositaires d'un corps
doctrinal pour le coup extrêmement
étroits extrêmement radical qui ne peut
pas intéressé une très grande majorité
de
deux français et des lecteurs donc à mon
avis c'est quand même joué à l'échec est
ce qu'on voit aussi hélas est
intéressant que dans les séparations que
révèle cette alliance c'est qu'une
partie de la gauche se dit on ne peut
pas comment dire suivent cette dérive
parce que sinon on va finir très peu
nombreux et très divisée parce qu'en
plus c'est un sacré intersectionnelle
c'est autant de divisions que par lui
donc mais je pense qu enfin le le taux
d'abstention record que l'on a connu
cette fois ci il raconte ça use
oui je pense qu'on lui toute une partie
des jeunes même des jeunes puisque c'est
sensé draguer les jeunes en fait ces
théories c'est sensé draguer les jeunes
les jeunes ne se sont pas reconnus là
dedans ils sont pas allés massivement
ils ne sont pas allés voter
donc si vous voulez moi je crois surtout
que la seule chose qu'on crée c1 entre
eux soit totale avec une partie de plus
en plus réduite de la population qui va
voter
et moi je ne comprends pas qu'il n'y pas
voyez notre président de la république
n'a rien trouvé mieux après que de
recevoir justin bieber 1 plutôt que de
faire un petit peu un mea culpa sur ce
que ce qu'avait été ces régionales ou en
tout cas essayer d'y réfléchir ensemble
lui préfère recevoir des stars a coûté
tant mieux pour lui chacun
chacun ses goûts mais en tout cas là on
a un vrai problème
je comprends pas en fait que les
politiques ne soient pas tous paniqué
parce que telle est leur légitimité à
être élu avec si peu de personnes qui
vont voter et moi même dans mon
entourage mais le peu de gens que je
connaissais qui allait voter ont voté
blanc
donc si les jeux là moi je serai
politique je serais vraiment terrorisés
oui mais la crise de leur moi je partage
votre point de vue mais la crise de la
représentation politique quotidienne moi
j'ajouterais la crise de la
représentation médiatique aussi réussi
des intérêts d'un certain nombre de
médias en disant et du coup le succès
d'un certain nombre d'autres médias en
herbe et il parle comme nous on nous
parle pas et c'est je pense que cette
crise permettrait à la droite de
retrouver un certain nombre de ces
thèmes en revanche la gauche les
abandonnés depuis tellement longtemps
en gros le tout le rôle social qu'elle
avait
la laïcité l'éducation nationale tout ça
ça fait quand même des années ça date
pas d'il ya deux ans quoi ça fait vingt
trente ans ça me paraît très très
difficile lorsqu'on est la gauche dite
républicaine qui a incarné manuel valls
ll est intéressante sur le plan
doctrinal
elle n'a jamais été très représentative
dans les urnes
et finalement on ne voit pas une go une
nouvelle gauche qui s'y reconnaît moi je
le déplore parce que je trouve assez
intéressant mais mais pour le moment
elle a une signification sociale et
politique dans le débat public
mais dans le le fonds du pays je sais
pas si elle est une possibilité auquel
les gens de foi à laquelle pardon à voir
en tout cas à l'évocation de justin
bieber à beaucourt je croyais que
c'était ringard et justin bien un peu
pensé il ya cinq ou dix ans a beaucoup
parlé cas il ya certains certains
internautes qui trouvent que d'ailleurs
c'était une honte bon je salue par
là-même kriss kross qui nous regardent
régulièrement une autre question par
rapport à cames à sa part revenir quand
même au thème de cette partie l'idée
d'un front républicain
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne idée
ou est-ce que c'est pas quand même
contre-productif aussi qu'on produit
contre du contre-productif qu'un front
républicain contre les le pen de ça
dépend pour qui l'utilisent candeur cob
christian jacob qui devait avoir tout
perdu
s'amuse à dire je demande aux candidats
de la république en marche de retirer
leurs listes parce que la gauche
radicale peut gagner
ils s'amusent ils s'amusent ils fait à
la république en marche parce que la
république doit marcher a fait donc le
l'idée de l'intimidation morale qui est
le principe du front républicain
est utilisé dans ce sens là après moi je
pense que c'est un une formule qui est
usée qui abîment un peu les mots quel
emploi et qui comment dire établi des
analogies historiques qui sont hors de
propos
c'est à dire qu'il ya des menaces
contemporaines il ya des forces
politiques plus hostile que d'autres
mais y'a pas la république n'est pas
menacée par les partis qui se présentent
aux élections aujourd'hui
d'abord elle n'est pas menacée parce que
dans leur programme ils ne la menace pas
et ensuite est pas menacée parce que ils
sont loin de pouvoir gagner alors
mélenchon on est sûr qu'il ne gagnera
pas et marine le pen
moi j'ai jamais cru qu'elle pouvait
gagner mais depuis un mois et demi on
nous expliquait que c'était le cas bon
voilà elle a fait 18 % je pense qu'on
voit comment la prochaine présidentielle
c'est terminé donc je jeu c'est un
instrument politique qui peut être utile
pour celui qui le manipulent
mais le principe moral je trouve n'est
pas du tout adapté à la situation
contemporaine
dans tous les cas vous n'êtes pas sur la
longueur d'onde que les internautes du
figaro qui disent oui à 60 18 mai ils se
vengent parce qu'ils aient dit le dire
dans l'autre sens c'est pour ça écoutez
sur sur la question du front républicain
moi je serais assez en accord avec
vincent trémolet de villers parce que tu
es le problème c'est que ça fait 20 ans
qu'on brandit le front républicain on
voit que ça n'a pas empêché au fond la
progression du rassemblement national et
l'instauration l'installation du
rassemblement national comme sans doute
le premier parti de france c'est sans
doute l'abstention le second c'est le
rassemblement national donc je pense que
ça n'a pas fonctionné de ce point de vue
du point de vue de l'augmentation de
l'abstention je pense que ça a joué
aussi parce que regarder quand renaud
muselier a commencé à dire qu'il allait
s'arranger